after years of Donald Trump slamming
Hillary Clinton for her private email
use demanding that Hillary be jailed for
it and also after months months after
finding out that Trump's own son-in-law
Jared Kushner had been using private
email and Trump's former chief of staff
Reince Priebus habit had been using
private email and a ton of other Trump
associates were using private email for
government business we have learned
based on the Washington Post reporting
that Trump's daughter Trump's unelected
daughter who is doing government work
even sat in for the Secretary of State
at meetings in the past she has been
using private email hundreds of messages
related to government business this
includes emails to cabinet officials and
political aides many of which violate
federal Records rules there is also a
larger story here which I've been
covering for a long time which is why is
Ivanka Trump doing government business
as an unelected family member of the
President of the United States and also
what about the mixing of public and
private because she is now
simultaneously involved with the same
email address in public issues that
she's involved with her father's
administration private issues related to
her clothing brand and it is all just
mixed together now with the added
characteristic of this private email
address now Hillary Clinton you can say
many things about Hillary Clinton but
she was basically just working period
there was no blending by Hillary Clinton
of her public and private activities
because she was effectively always
working and asked about all of this
Ivanka's first reaction was I had no
idea what the rules were would any of
the loc Hillary up crowd over the emails
accept Hillary saying I had no idea why
would they accept that explanation when
it's clear that they've been arguing all
the time malicious intent and that
anyone in these positions would know
exactly what they were doing well does
the same standard apply to Ivanka so the
neck
thing is let me prepare you for the
talking points that you're going to hear
from the right about this the right will
say and they're already saying it well
yeah evanka used personal email but
unlike Hillary Ivanka wasn't sending
classified information well we don't
know that for a fact yet but that
doesn't actually distinguish the two
situations because remember Hillary
Clinton wasn't sending emails with
information that was classified at the
time some of the contents were later
classified but that was after Hillary
Clinton had been a party to those emails
chains so again that's not really an
argument next argument you'll hear well
Ivanka used personal email but unlike
Hillary Ivanka wasn't using it to
obscure and hide what she was working on
and saying to people we actually don't
know that that goes to intent and
legally speaking it's not at all clear
that that's relevant here and then
you'll also hear from the wright-patt
that Ivanka used personal email but she
wasn't running a server for it as it
happens the private email that Ivanka
was using is from a domain that she
shares with her husband shared Kushner
so yeah as far as we know that domain
isn't physically on a server in her
house but what does it matter you can
control a virtual private server you can
control a remotely managed server in the
exact same way that you can control a
server physically and it's basically
irrelevant they own the domain the
domain is provisioned and configured the
exact way they want that email to work
and that to me is one that I think is
not being properly debunked Pat this
idea of it's not a private server well
let's think about exactly what that
means because in reality it's one of
those distinctions without really being
a difference yeah I think the two cases
are very very similar and I think it
just goes to show how ridiculous it was
that this was such a sticking point
during the campaign a reason that people
wouldn't support Hillary Clinton and
maybe a reason why she lost too and I
don't think that we should be locking
Ivanka Trump over this I mean that
sounds a little bit too ridiculous to me
but the hypocrisy point is a good one
and it's one that I think should stick
the hypocrisy is the main point and
please let this be the first thing Jim
Acosta asks about when he gets back in
that press briefing room in front of
Donald Trump let it be this as Pat is
pointing out they're hypocrites to the
enth degree they don't actually care
about this the same way they don't care
about the debt the same way they don't
care about any of the issues that are
merely political footballs that they use
for their gain when it's convenient and
when it's not if they ignore them am i
way off on this one am i missing some
fundamental fact here that would change
my opinion let me know I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show follow us there and
let me know your thoughts today's
program is sponsored in part by deputies
offering you $10 just for trying their
free service at Debbie Ty's dot-com
slash Pakman this is a free app that can
actually help a lot of people get into
better situations with their personal
finances because what Debbie ties does
is it turns any credit card into a debit
card meaning you can still earn your
credit card rewards and build credit and
get points or miles or whatever it is
that your credit card offers but you
eliminate the risk of going into debt
you can't afford or of accruing late
fees or paying interest because when you
sign up and link your credit card to
your checking account you use your
credit card like you normally would and
at the end of the day debbye ties will
withdraw however much you charged on
your card that day from your checking
account and set it aside
without overdrafting your account at the
end of the month deputies has already
paid your credit card bill for you on
time and automatically this is a really
good way for people who want an easier
way to pay bills on time and it's also
excellent for people who are trying to
stay on a budget and not go into debt by
spending more money than they have it's
also her
fect if you're looking to have a
risk-free hassle-free way of building
credit and earning rewards points and
once he set it up you don't have to go
in and mess with anything it's
completely automatic this is a really
important thing from what when I got my
first credit card with like a five
hundred dollar limit or something like
that at that point I decided I don't
charge anything I can't pay off at the
end of the month and I have thought of
my credit card as a debit card forever
and it's a really great practice for
people to get into you can enjoy debet
eyes totally free for as long as you
want by clicking the link under this
video and debet eyes will give you ten
dollars just for trying it out